I'm not going to stand here now and give
you a list of names as to who I think
will defect to you Kip but I will say
this I would be very surprised given the
electoral mathematics given what
registered does to the kind of
constituency where maybe the Tories hold
a seat but labour are a very big second
I would be very surprised given where we
are if there weren't more defections
between now and the next election they
won't happen today they would happen
tomorrow but over the course of the next
few weeks people will be thinking and
perhaps some of them saying to
themselves you know what I've got a got
a better chance of winning on a purple
ticket that i have on a blue ticket well
considering that we were up against a
Conservative Party who used the Prime
Minister as their pin-up boy he visited
here five times they had more troops on
the ground yesterday I've ever seen any
British by-election they've made more
phone calls yesterday that has ever
happened before oh goodness knows how
the conservative campaign comes within
spending limits that's quite a mystery
to me so when they said they'd throw in
the kitchen sink at this my goodness me
they did and despite that and despite
their boasts and despite their belief
that they would win Rochester you know
we have beaten the governing party of
the day in this sort of life death
struggle so I think for us it represents
a huge huge victory it says to people
that if you vote you Kip you get you Kip
and I think what it really does is to
make any prediction for next year's
general election frankly irrelevant I
think the whole thing now is up in the
air it's very very difficult to call